[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: So, welcome to
Large Scale Multiplayer Gaming
with Open Source.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I am a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud for games.
And we're here to talk about
some multiplayer game stuff.
Does that sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
MARK MANDEL: Yay!
Awesome.
Wow, you really are excited.
This is fantastic.
All right, great.
So before we get
started, I would
love to know a bit more
about all of you, just
so I can get a sense of who you
all are and what you all do.
And we can tailor the
content a little bit.
So how many people here
work in the games industry?
Oh, a good number of you.
Excellent, awesome.
How many of you work
on multiplayer games?
Cool.
How many of you want to
work in multiplayer games?
Some of you.
How many people were just
like, games are cool,
this sounds like fun?
AUDIENCE: Woo.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine, too.
That's cool.
All right, so we'll cover
some foundational stuff,
and we'll cover--
so we'll get deeper
into some projects.
And we'll talk about some
interesting and fun things.
So before we get
started, though, I
want to put some constraints
on things a little bit.
When we say the words
multiplayer games,
that can be a very broad
and distributed set
of games outside in the world.
So I want to bring
that in a little.
So the types of
multiplayer games
that I want to talk about today
are your very fast-paced online
competitive multiplayer games.
So we're talking your
"Overwatches," your "Fortnites"
your "Apex Legends," your
"Rocket Leagues," those kinds
of really fast-paced,
latency sensitive,
online, real time
multiplayer games.
Those are the types of
games I want talk about.
Because they have some
particularly unique constraints
and have some particularly
unique problems that they
need to have solved to
work in a reliable fashion.
So we're going to actually
see this demo today.
I actually use a
FPS called Xonotic.
Anyone here know Xonotic?
A couple people, awesome.
It's an open source FPS.
If anyone played, like,
Unreal Tournament 2000
or any derivatives
from there, you're
probably quite familiar
with how it works.
It has Capture the Flag.
It has a lot of the classic
modes, all that kind of stuff.
And we'll have a
look at that later.
But that's very much the vein
of the type of multiplayer games
that I want to be
talking about today.
So, traditionally, how do
these kind of games work?
There are several models
for how to do this.
But I want to talk about one
very particular one, commonly
referred to as
dedicated game servers.
Because it has become one of
the most prevalent patterns that
is used in especially AAA
large scale multiplayer games.
So what does this look like?
So you might have, say, a couple
of players, who are like, hey,
I would like to play a game.
So, cool.
They take their game
clients, and they usually
connect to some kind
of matchmaking system.
So this matchmaking
system's job is
to potentially take maybe
hundreds of thousands
of players, take them
all in and say, OK,
let's look at things like
maybe their skill rating, maybe
their social graph,
maybe other aspects
of their gameplay
experience, and group them
together into a single gameplay
like group that's going
to be a good experience, right?
Like group me with people who
are likewise in my skill level,
so it's not an
unbalanced matched.
Or if there are
particular friends
that I like playing with
a lot, put them together
because that's a really
fun experience for me.
And so this is a really
interesting problem
because you do have to
process potentially thousands
upon hundreds of thousands
of players at once,
but the idea being that, yeah,
let's get a good gameplay
experience happening
between the players
that we have available
that are online
and waiting to play a game.
So once we've solved
that hard problem, cool.
We've grouped together
our game, our players.
We've got a group.
We then need to create a
dedicated game server for them
to play on.
So this could be a whole
talk unto of itself,
but essentially, a
dedicated game server
is a full simulation of what
happens inside your game,
like where your players
are, what they're doing.
It's authoritative.
It tells everything what
it is that it needs to do.
So once we have our
players together,
we need to talk to some sort of
dedicated game server manager
system.
And this system's
job is potentially
to talk to thousands
upon thousands
of machines that are distributed
around the world, all right?
Because we need to have these
machines close to our players.
Because latency matters.
It matters a lot.
So we're going to talk
to thousands of machines
around the world and
basically be like, OK, we
need to spin up one of
these dedicated game
server processes.
And therefore,
like which one has
memory, which one has
enough CPU, what's
its latency metrics compared to
what my players are, et cetera.
Spin it up, and then turn
around and be like, cool,
it's spun up.
Now we need an IPM port.
Where is this thing located?
So we have an IPM port for
this dedicated game server.
Send all that information
way back up the pipe
to those two players that
are wanting to play a game.
And then they can make a direct
connection to that game server
by the IPM port.
So they can interact directly
with that in-memory simulation
as that player plays the game.
So, it's a lot of work.
Usually speaking, a
lot of this is bespoke.
Most companies generally
do this themselves.
It's probably less than ideal.
So the things I want
to talk about today
is very much what if there was--
whoops, sorry, I'll go back--
what if there was some
sort of open source
standard for
matchmaking, wherein
you don't have to solve
some of the hard problems
around how do I process hundreds
of thousands of players?
Wouldn't that be kind of nice?
By the same token,
wouldn't it be really nice
if there was some sort of open
source standard for game server
management, right?
I don't really care
about how to distribute
this workload geographically
and how do I process--
like, orchestrate these
things going up and down.
I just want to write
my game servers.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
Sound like fun?
Good.
Before we get started,
hands up, people here
who know what Kubernetes is.
A lot of you, fantastic.
Awesome.
Both of the projects
we're going to talk today
are heavily based on Kubernetes.
But I want to bring it up for
three very important reasons.
Now if you're not
familiar with Kubernetes,
at a very core level, the
way I like to explain it,
is a system for
programmatically being
able to run software across
lots and lots of machines.
Everything else on top of that
is really just nice sugar,
but it's open source and
you can run it anywhere.
And this is super
important because when
latency counts for
multiplayer games,
being able to put
your infrastructure
close to your player base,
super, super important.
So the projects I'm talking
about today are open source,
and they will run on Kubernetes.
And you can run Kubernetes
wherever it is you need to.
So that means then if you want
to run it on us, like GKE,
awesome, love it, great.
But if you have
coverage, like maybe
in particular areas of
the world where you just
happen to have a player
base we don't cover so well,
you can run it there on your
own hardware, on another cloud.
That's really, really important.
By the same token, you want to
run it in your own QA centers,
you want to run it
on your own machines,
you can totally do that as well.
Secondly, this is
also really important.
Standing on the shoulders of
giants, obviously, many of you
are familiar.
Kubernetes has a huge
number of developers
working on it and a massive
ecosystem surrounding it.
So we can take advantage
of all those tools as well.
Finally, simplicity is
really important, too.
Usually, I talk to
a lot of customers.
And usually when I
talk to customers,
they have one system for
their account management,
and their marketplace,
and their inventory,
and their player systems.
And then when it comes to
multiplayer dedicated game
servers, they're a
completely different system.
If we can solidify on one base
platform for all our systems
across the board, that's a lot
less ops knowledge, a lot less
difference in tooling.
Really, we can
really just not have
to contextually switch as
we operate from one platform
to another.
Cool.
Kubernetes gets me very excited.
Fantastic.
So let's get stuck into
the types of projects
we want to talk about.
So we were talking
about matchmaking.
Open Match is a
project that came out,
I want to say somewhere between
six to eight months ago.
It's an open source
matchmaking framework.
And I want to emphasize
the term framework here.
It is built with flexibility,
scalability, and extensibility.
What does that mean?
Basically, we want to solve the
hard problems for matchmaking,
but still allow you to
provide your custom match
logic in the way
that makes sense
for your game and your players.
So horizontal
scalability, that stuff
shouldn't be a problem for you.
Really just focusing on
exactly the gameplay experience
you want-- that's the
thing we care about.
So, we're very flexible.
We allow you to provide
attributes for your players
as they come in
and out, basically
arbitrarily as you need.
And custom match
functions-- essentially,
if you can put it inside
a Docker container,
you can write a match function.
So we don't restrict you in any
way in terms of what language
you want to write it in, what
platform you write it in.
As long as you can put
it inside a container,
you are good to go.
And the big thing
I think that gets
me most excited about
Open Match is really
the way it works concurrently.
What we've seen traditionally
in matchmakers quite often,
they hit certain scaling limits.
And that was a problem we
very much wanted to solve.
And I'll show a demo in
a little bit about this.
But really, what we
want to be able to solve
those hard problems of like,
I have a 100,000 players
coming in.
How do I concurrently
process match functions
over these things?
We want to solve
those problems for you
and leave that kind of more game
specific stuff to yourselves.
So we'll have a look at that.
So, doo doo doo doo doo.
If we can switch over to
my demo screen, please.
Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
All right, so I have an
empty Kubernetes cluster.
As you can see, it's
not entirely empty.
I do have-- there we go.
If I get config maps.
I do have the configuration for
Open Match already installed.
It's just the
standard config map
that you get with the example,
but with debugging turned off.
And I'm going to
install Open Match.
So those not familiar--
not my example, sorry--
we're just going to
install some YAML files.
So Open Match uses Redis for
its persistent data store.
You can either use
one in cluster,
which we're going to do
here, or you could also
use something like Memorystore
or any other managed Redis.
Beautiful.
And that's going to install
a bunch of stuff, right?
And that's really it.
There's nothing much
more else to it.
There's a bunch of components
inside Open Match that
are configurable, and we can
mix and match a few things.
I'm not going to talk
too much about it today,
but those exist.
Now I'm going to copy paste here
because these are big commands.
And we're going to put some
players inside Open Match.
So what we're going to
do here is basically
put in seven cycles of
10,000 game players,
or 10,000 generated
players for us.
Take a little second
for it to come up.
Come on, run.
So we're going to
spin up 70,000 players
and insert those inside
our Open Match cluster.
You know you want to work.
The demo gods apparently
love me today.
Come on, you can do it.
I believe in you.
There we go.
Took a second.
Wonderful.
OK, so this is generating
10,000 players.
We'll see a few
numbers of these.
There we go.
So there we go.
Beautiful.
Obviously, it hadn't downloaded
the image for a while,
so that was taking
a little second.
So that's now generating
some players, right?
So 70,000, not a bad number.
Here we go, here
we go, here we go.
So while it's doing that, I'm
going to grab the next command.
So what we're going to
do is we're actually
going to run some matchmaking
once this is done.
So you can actually see
the concurrency in action.
All right, so we have
70,000 players, beautiful.
All right, give me bash.
Lovely, and I'm going to
steal this command because I
can never remember how it goes.
Wonderful.
So what I'm going
to do is-- whoops.
That takes a second
to come up sometimes.
Let me run that again.
There we go.
That ran really quickly.
So what we did there is we ran--
let me scroll up.
We ran a matchmaking
function, just a really simple
matchmaking function that
we have inside the example.
And we ran it with
a concurrency of 2.
All right, just
concurrency of 2.
And what we're actually
doing is we're looking
for groups of 16 players.
And so it's going
to run through.
It's splitting that up.
That's just really not
the best wrapping there.
But you can see that
we're splitting it
up into teams of 16.
And then it splits it
up into four pools,
each of about 14,000 players.
And unsurprisingly, this
is pretty successful
trying to find groups
of 16 inside 14,000.
We have quite a
few to choose from.
We have number of successes, 4.
64 players matched.
And we have a throughput of
about 26 players per second,
which is not a lot,
but we can do better.
So, let's actually
do the same thing,
but let's bump that number
up to a concurrency of 20.
So this usually
takes 10, 20 seconds.
You'll start to see here,
it'll say insufficient players.
That's because some of
our players' pool sizes
are less than 16.
And that happens in some
cases, and that's fine.
But it's going to break apart
all the players that we have.
And this is configurable.
You can kind of play with
how things get broken apart.
And then process a much
larger number of players,
allowing us to get much better
throughput inside Open Match.
There we go.
All right, beautiful.
So now we can see
here, we've actually
matched about 4,200 players--
a little better than the
64 odd we had before.
Now we can get
through a throughput
of more like 168
players per second.
So this is how we can start to
distribute the workload of what
happens inside Open
Match to be able to get
higher throughput without--
we really didn't have
to change anything
inside our matching function.
We just changed our
concurrency, which
means we get some much
nicer massive throughput.
Can we go back to slides please?
Awesome.
All right, so this is
a bit better, right?
We didn't have to
write our matchmaker.
Instead, with this
custom matchmaker
we've put in Open Match, we
use common open source things
like Redis, which many of you
are probably familiar with.
And we're able to insert
Kubernetes and install
Open Match on top of
that Kubernetes cluster
as a customer appliance.
And we're good to go.
But that's great.
We can still do the same
thing we had before,
where we had players connecting
to dedicated game servers.
Whoops, I want that sign.
There we go.
But we still have this
Server Manager, yeah?
We still have this
bespoke thing that it
would be really nice if I didn't
have to build, quite honestly.
So this is where
we get into Agones.
So Agones is another
open source project.
It was built in
collaboration with Ubisoft.
And it is an open source
project for hosting, scaling,
and orchestrating dedicated game
servers on top of Kubernetes.
I'm sure that wasn't
surprising at this point.
I'm sure many of you
were seeing that coming.
It's been a really
great collaboration
between us and Ubisoft.
I just want to highlight it.
They've been able to bring
their institutional knowledge
about how to run dedicated game
servers in large multiplayer
games over to us.
And we've been able to bring
our knowledge of Kubernetes
and open source.
And it's just been
really lovely.
I have to be completely
honest with you.
So, super delighted to be
working with them on this.
So, let's look at
how Agones works.
Very similarly, right, if you
have a dedicated game server
and you can put it
inside a container,
you are pretty much good to go.
All right?
I assume we're all fairly
familiar with Docker
containers.
That's something we're
all familiar with.
Awesome.
There is a dedicated SDK
that needs to be integrated
in some way, shape, or form.
That SDK tells us things like,
hey, this game server is ready,
whether it's healthy or not,
access to configuration,
things like that.
But this is pretty easy to do.
It's not an onerous task.
We already support a variety
of languages, including C++,
and Node, and Rust.
But it is all GRPC
and/or REST based.
So the short answer
is, if you have
a game server in any
language, we can support it.
You'll be fine.
Actually, the unreal SDK will
be coming out this afternoon,
once I put the
release candidate out.
So that'll be nice, too.
We have more stuff coming, yeah.
So, hands up people here who
have written Kubernetes YAML
files?
Many of you, cool.
If you haven't, that's fine.
It's like one of
the declarative ways
that you can tell
Kubernetes to do stuff.
Anything you see
here in a YAML file,
you can also do it directly
through the Kubernetes API
as well.
So, once you install Agones,
what it actually is doing
is extending Kubernetes itself
to provide it new nouns--
basically, new
actions that it knows
how to do things with natively.
And this is like one of
the really cool things
about Kubernetes, is standing
of the shoulder of giants that
gets me very, very excited.
So once you install
Agones, it understands
what a game server is.
And it understands game
server life cycles.
And this is really important
because game servers
are kind of special in that when
you don't have players on game
servers, and you spin them up,
if you delete game servers that
don't have players on
them, nobody seems to mind.
But when you delete game servers
that do have players on them,
players seem to mind a lot.
If they get their game shut
down in the middle of their game
play experience,
they're not happy.
They post things on Reddit.
They tend to write
things, Steam reviews.
It's just bad for everyone.
So once we have this installed,
suddenly, Agones really
does understand, oh,
there are players on here.
We'll have a look at that
a little bit later as well.
So here, we define
a game server.
We can give it a name,
a referenceable name,
or even have it
create one for us.
We can specify the port
policies we want to have.
Agones will manage
dynamic port allocation,
so we can do that direct
connection we saw earlier.
And then finally, we
specify the container
that we want our
game server to be.
For those of you who are more
familiar with Kubernetes,
you can run a full
pod spec here as well.
So if you want to run multiple
containers, or volume mounts,
or config maps, or any of that
cool stuff, you totally can.
But we can do better than
just individual game servers
as well.
We can do fleets
of game servers.
So traditionally speaking,
what you probably
want to do with
your game servers
is spin them up and have
a warm set ready to go,
waiting for players to come in.
Game servers can take a
little while to spin up.
So you want to have those
sitting there ready to go.
So if people are familiar
with pods and deployments,
very similar.
We have game servers and fleets.
So fleets are just
lots of game servers.
We specify how many
replicas we want,
and then we specify a
game server specification.
And it's the job of the
fleet to ensure that we
have lots of these ready to go.
That's really it.
If one of them falls over
or maybe one of them ends,
we make sure we have
another one spun up,
and it keeps them
alive and healthy.
So here we have the
Xonotic game server here,
and we have two replicas
of it available.
Now, this is the fun
thing, and I think,
again, something particular
to game servers themselves.
We don't have load
balancers, right?
So how do we get
players to a game server
and mark it as, hey, players
are playing on this thing?
So we have this concept of
what we call allocation.
So here, I show it
as the YAML file.
You would probably do it
if you are implementing it
programmatically through
the Kubernetes API.
But I say to
Agones, hey, I would
like to create me an
allocation, please.
Grab me a game server in
this particular instance out
of the Xonotic fleet,
and mark it as allocated.
And do it for me atomically.
And do it for me safely.
Right?
That's an interesting
and fun problem, right?
Other things could be
happening to your servers.
They could be
coming up and down.
But Agones solves that sort
of infrastructure problem
of saying, oh, yeah, you've
got like 10,000 game servers
running in this cluster.
Awesome.
Here's one that's safe, right?
And it's now marked
as allocated.
And so we know there
are players on it.
So why don't I show
you that in action?
Would that be kind of fun?
Sweet.
All right, can we switch
back over to demo?
We already have.
Oh, you're all amazing.
So first thing I want
to do is install Agones.
I'm going to use Helm.
Helm's a package
manager for Kubernetes.
So if you've ever used anything
like Yum, or Apt, or Homebrew,
very much in that vein.
So I'm just going
to install Agones.
I like Helm.
Helm's great.
So it's going to
take the Helm chart.
It's going to install it.
Boom, there we go.
It was literally that
easy, which is lovely.
I can actually show
you, get pods namespace.
We can now see that we have
several components already
just sitting there.
These are just the
parts of Agones.
We actually really don't
care about them too much.
So let's write, let's
run a Xonotic fleet,
like we just saw earlier, right?
So I can apply -f
examples/xonotic/fleet.yaml.
Boom.
OK, cool.
So this creates a fleet.
Now what's really cool about
extending Kubernetes as well,
is all the extensions
go through the API,
all the way down to the tooling.
So I can now say get fleets.
And it can show me fleets.
And we'll see things,
like, oh, cool,
we have two desired, awesome.
That's what we had before.
And two of them are ready.
We can also look at them
slightly differently.
We can also see game server.
Right?
We can see we have two that
are available and ready to go
as well.
That's awesome.
But two games servers, boring.
Let's get more.
Let's scale our fleet.
Also, I don't know
if you noticed,
but I get tab
completion on here, too.
I love this.
Say, like 200 game servers,
that's way more fun, right?
Much better number.
And we can look at this in
a couple of different ways.
So here, we have a fleet, right?
We currently have 200.
They're going to start
coming up to becoming ready.
They spin up really quick.
There we go, 57 looking great.
Lovely.
If we come across to
here, you can actually
also start to see
some of the metrics
that we have available
to us as well.
This usually runs a
little bit behind.
Because it pulls
every 30 seconds.
It'll pick up in a sec.
But we can start seeing things
like rate type, how many game
servers we have, what state
they're in, count per type.
So all the sort of
metrics that you
need as well for running
game servers at scale
come bundled in with Agones.
Similarly, you have similar
things in Open Match.
But these are the sort of things
that you shouldn't have to care
about as a game developer.
This should just be
stuff that you all need.
How many game servers you're
running is a standard metric
we should all just have.
This shouldn't be stuff that
you have to build yourself.
So we can see all
sorts of stuff.
And this is just one dashboard
out of many dashboards
that we have inside Agones.
So we have a look over here.
OK, so this is actually
the dashboard's
running slightly behind.
But we can see we
have 200 ready.
That's amazing.
So let's allocate.
Let's do that.
That'll be fun.
Create -f examples/xonotic
/gameserverallocation.
So I would probably normally
do this through an API,
like I keep saying.
But I'm going to do it
through the YAML file
because that's what
used to using here.
And I'm just going
to write -o yaml,
so we can see the response
when it finally finishes.
So boom.
OK, so that's given us
an allocated game server.
There's a bunch of stuff up top.
The bit I really care
about here is this, right?
State allocated, we have
an IP, we have a port,
we have a game server
that's been given to us
that's essentially sacrosanct.
So, let's play a game.
Does that sound like fun?
Just move that over.
Yeah, this is the fun bit.
All right.
Let's plug it.
Let's see if I can type
really small things
in front of a live audience.
41:7899, join.
Beautiful black screen
is actually good.
All right, so this is going
to connect to the game server
that we basically-- we spun up
200 of these entire cluster.
Then we allocated it, and it
looked inside of the cluster
and was like, hey, let's
spin up one of these.
And then, there we go.
I'm going to play
on my trackpad.
This is me playing Xonotic on a
cluster that's running US east
or US west, one or the other.
There are some players
around here somewhere.
Without fail, there we go.
As soon as I play in front
of a group of people,
there's never anyone around.
Oh, there we go.
Ha, yeah.
The most important part of
this whole talk, really.
All right, cool.
That was fun, but I actually
want to show some other fun
stuff off, too.
So let's do a couple
more allocations
because I want to show off.
This is cool.
So we can see here that we
have three game servers that
are allocated, right?
We essentially have
three game servers
that have people playing on it.
So let's scale this down.
We're like, actually, these
game servers, we don't like it.
There's something wrong with
it, something like that.
So let's just say replica 0.
Flip the table, and just be
like, we hate this thing now.
So that's going to
start scaling that down.
But we're always going to see
that those three allocated
servers always stay there.
Agones does a whole
bunch of stuff.
But this, I think, is like
one of the core, basic things
that it understands,
is that while we might
have a variety of
these being shut down,
we don't touch
allocated game servers.
Super, super important.
We don't interrupt a
player playing a game.
Don't ever do it.
It's bad.
Bad, bad, bad, bad.
So, lots and lots of fun.
So yeah, if we actually run
that again, there we go.
So we still always, we'll see
those allocated game servers,
until the players finish
playing their games,
and those game servers
self shut down.
Very important stuff.
Cool.
Can we go back to
slides, please?
Excellent.
Wonderful.
OK.
So, things are always
better with friends.
So let's see if we can
make this work together.
So we do have stuff
wherein we can
make these talk to each other.
So what we can do is we
can install basically
what we commonly refer to
as a director, or basically,
glue code between Open Match
and a game server scaler,
which can be custom
if you so desire.
So that a matchmaker can take
the things in Open Match,
right?
You run your custom
match logic there.
It can talk to Agones and be
like, hey, I've got players.
Let's match make
and make a game.
And then that game server
can be marked as allocated.
Those players can
then play that game,
and continue on, and
have a really good time.
So, one slide,
we're back to demo.
Fun.
So in cooking show parlance,
here's one I prepared earlier.
So I already have--
whoops, that's al, not
what I want as all.
I already have Open
Match installed.
I have Agones installed.
There's a bunch of stuff
already in this cluster.
But what we're
going to do is we're
going to create the fleet,
like we saw previously.
So that's going to
create a fleet for us
of a really simple game server.
It literally just takes a UDP
packet with some text in it,
and it spits out a log.
I know Xonotic is
super exciting,
but this is just very simple
for demonstrative purposes.
And then what we're
also going to do
is we're going to
install the director.
Basically, this is the
glue code that says,
hey, this is how I
want Open Match to talk
to Agones to allocate
game servers for me,
basically in the way
that makes sense for me.
So cool.
That's good to go.
Lovely.
I'm going to grab this from down
here because it's also got--
oh yes, there we go.
Beautiful.
And then I'm going to
write a little script here.
make sure this is ready.
Beautiful.
So this is going to
do a couple of things.
So we're going to work on a
much smaller scale this time.
We're just going to
work with one player,
just so we can see the
flow all the way through.
So here, this is just going to
generate one player for us--
very simple, right?
Nothing too complicated.
But then we're
going to spin up a--
once we've got one player,
Open Match in this instance
is going to be like, oh, we
only need one player for a game.
So cool, we can match make them.
We're going to hit Enter.
And it's going to go,
cool, we have a player.
Awesome.
We're going to go
and tell Agones,
hey, allocate my game server.
So this here, IPM import of
the game server that just got
allocated to us from Agones--
awesome.
Next, this little script is
going to spin up a client.
Lovely.
So there's a little client.
We can use it to send UDP
messages to the allocated game
server.
So why don't we actually
pop over to our other tab?
We have a look at
our game servers.
You see we have one that's--
we have two that's allocated?
That's fun.
Let me see which one
is going on there.
7616, I just want to get
the logs from the right one.
76-- so it's this one.
Beautiful.
This may have been lying
around from before, so kubectl
logs -f, simple udp.
Beautiful.
All right, so we can
see that that's running.
Now let's send a little command.
We'll say, Hello!
Now I want you to ignore
the error bit at the bottom.
Because demos always
fail the day before.
But the bit that I care about
is where it says, hello, right?
So I've got
connectivity now, right?
I essentially can
play this game.
I can send packets to it.
In theory, it should be
able to send them back,
but we'll ignore that for now.
But we can work that
all the way through.
So essentially, we've been
able to do the full stack
from going from matchmaking all
the way through to allocation
of game server and having
a person play the game.
Now, we can quit this
and see something else
that's also kind of cool.
So what's going to happen
now is this little script
is going to start just
allocating game servers.
It's basically going
to keep adding players
to the matchmaking queue.
As it keeps doing that, it's
going to keep going to Agones
and saying, hey, can I
have the game server?
Now one thing we haven't
talked a bit about today
is the auto scaling
capabilities of Agones.
So here we have one of
our fleet auto scalers
already set up for us.
And we can see that
as we add players,
our allocated game
servers goes back up to 6.
The auto scaler is
starting to kick off.
Right?
We've got this at a
really low number.
So you can see the
numbers go really slowly.
Otherwise, it zooms
up really fast.
But you can start to
see the numbers start
to rise, as we have
the server to say, hey,
can we have two ready game
servers at any point in time?
And so every 30 seconds, it's
going to kick over and say, OK,
cool, there we go.
Let's add in number
two, and then we'll
add some more matchmaking to it.
And then we'll just
keep on rising through.
So we have some nice
functionality there
for auto scaling as well,
which is super cool.
Awesome.
Can I go back to slides, please?
Excellent.
All right.
So what does this mean?
So just wrap this up with
nice, visual diagrams.
So we add the players.
They want to play a game.
And in this instance
now, they're
going to talk to Open Match.
All right, we're going
to have our custom match
logic in there.
Right?
We're going to distribute
that player load over lots
and lots of machines, right?
We can do that for
you, which is lovely.
And you just worry about
your custom match logic.
From there, Open Match can talk
directly through the Kubernetes
API, right?
Usually through a director
or something similar
that's hooked into
Open Match to tell it
how we want it to allocate
game servers through Agones.
Agones itself can then look at
a fleet of game servers that
are already prewarmed and
ready to go, pull one out
atomically, and be like,
all right, this one here,
that's allocated, and
hand that information
all the way back
up to the players
who want to play a game.
Then finally, those players
can connect directly
to that game server,
as we saw here
and as we saw with
the Xonotic demo,
and continue to play that game.
We didn't have to build
a lot of bespoke stuff.
We can work on an
open standard, which
means it can run anywhere.
We can really just kind of
stand on the shoulders of giants
ourselves as game developers
and take advantage
of the tools that
already exist and really
focus on the game play
state and the game
play mechanics and
those aspects that
really matter inside our game.
So there's a bunch more
to both of these projects
that we don't have time
to talk about today.
I know I mentioned
it a bunch, but I
want to hammer it home
anyway about working
on cloud providers.
It works across all
cloud providers.
Basically, all these projects
work on Vanilla Kubernetes.
There's nothing special
in any of those.
Both projects have auto
scaling capabilities.
We saw some of
that inside Agones.
There's some more as well.
Agones works with the
Kubernetes auto scaler.
Open Match has similar auto
scaling capabilities as well.
Both projects have
local development tools,
so if you don't want to
spin up an entire Kubernetes
cluster locally, you're able
to use some lightweight tooling
to be able to
access and interact
with and develop with both
of those projects as well.
And as we saw briefly
as well, both projects
have metrics and
dashboards, right?
Metrics is really
important for those day
three, day four operations.
So we want to make sure that the
standard metrics that you all
need to do those kind of
roles come along with both
of these projects as well.
On top of that, both
of these projects
have pretty solid roadmaps.
Agones is still
technically alpha.
We are slated to go 1.0
at some point this year.
Yes, that is a broad statement.
I'm very happy with
broad statements.
You'll see a lot
of things coming.
More performance
improvements-- we've already
done a whole bunch
of performance
work, and we've made it
drastically more performant
than it was before.
The more metrics as well.
We're going to do more
commercial engines,
as I said, [INAUDIBLE] well,
the release candidate today.
We're working on Unity soon.
It's already on the 1.0 roadmap.
How to sort out multi-cluster
is also front of mind.
You're probably going to want
to run multiple little clusters
around the world.
So how you do
multi-cluster orchestration
and multi-cluster allocation
is already in the works.
And you can see some work
in the current release
candidate for that as well.
Also, Windows hosting--
many game developers
use Windows machines.
People want Windows hosting.
Thankfully, in Kubernetes 1.14,
the GA support for Windows
is there.
We're just waiting on
that to trickle down
into cloud providers as well.
So lots of good stuff in that.
On top of that, Open Match
also has a quite good roadmap
coming up.
They want to look at a
long-lived matching logic.
So for example, if you
just want to have a service
that's running up
and you consistently
hit that so that you can
consistently hit that endpoint
to run your custom match logic,
more metrics and dashboards
there.
Player and match tracing
is a big thing again.
So you can trace
what is happening
with each individual player as
they go through your system.
And they also want
to look to increase
and develop their build
chain for development tooling
as well.
I would be very remiss
if I didn't mention it.
If you want to try out Agones,
it's currently running 0.8.1,
so it's a couple
of versions behind.
But if you just want a simple
getting started experience,
with Agones, you can go to
the Google Cloud Marketplace
now, click a couple
of buttons, and get
a cluster up and running.
And you can take it for a
spin, so it's super nice.
Finally, before we
wrap up everything,
I definitely want to
say both projects are
very alive, very active.
But we're always looking for
more contributors, more people
to provide feedback.
So if you are
interested, definitely
get involved on Slack.
Come hang out with us
on GitHub file bugs,
send feature requests.
We definitely are looking
for a diverse set of opinions
from a wide variety of people
from the games industry
to come help us
make these projects
the best they possibly can be.
That is the power
of open source.
But before you run off as well,
if you have any questions,
I'll be around at
the conference.
If you go over into
the demo area build
in scale for Google
Cloud, you can
come talk to us as well
about both of these projects
and see a demonstration as well.
Finally, if you want to
follow us on Twitter,
I'm @Neurotic, because I
joined Twitter in 2006,
and that's something
you could do in 2006.
But you can also follow the
Agones project on Agones dev,
but you can also see Agones at
agones.dev and openmatch.dev
for more information.
Finally, thank you so much for
spending the last 40 minutes
with me.
I know your time is valuable,
so I really appreciate it.
And I hope you all
have a wonderful
I/O. Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]